en esta ciudad rusa cerca de la frontera
con ucrania se escuchan las explosiones
esporádicas a lo lejos a pesar de estar
a sólo unos kilómetros de distancia de
los combates los residentes de obras de
rostov no parecían demasiado preocupados
por la guerra
boyd eastick a cabo no hay combate como
tal la federación rusa está realizando
ejercicios tácticos en el área de sus
territorios giratoria
no creo que este sea un conflicto a gran
escala realmente lo dudo y hay
injusticia en ucrania los nazis están en
el poder durante meses los medios
estatales rusos han impulsado esta misma
narrativa para justificar la invasión de
ucrania pintan a los líderes ucranianos
como nazis beligerantes y títeres de
occidente y a las tropas rusas como
libertadores que intervienen para
prevenir un supuesto en un sitio no
existe a pesar que el kremlin no
proporcionó evidencia para respaldar
estas acusaciones muchos rusos están
convencidos de que putin está librando
una guerra defensiva para proteger a
rusia y liberar a ucrania sin embargo
algunos todavía sienten simpatía y
compasión por sus vecinos ucranianos
lo principal es entender que no es culpa
de los civiles de esta buena política
esta es una guerra de políticos y los
civiles solo están sufriendo lo que está
pasando en el país
desafiando la narrativa oficial miles de
personas en más de 50 ciudades rusas
salieron a las calles el jueves para
protestar contra la guerra pero más de
1.700 personas fueron arrestadas una
señal de que las autoridades rusas
intentan silenciar a sus escépticos y
críticos